معنا من غلاف غزه مراسلنا الياس كرام
الياس كيف بدات
وتيره عمليات القصف و الاشتباكات خلال
الساعات الماضيه خاصه في المناطق الشماليه
من قطاع غزه وعلى وقعها ايضا كيف تبدو
تصريحات
الاسرائيليه سلم نحن امام تطور جديد في
الدقائق الاخيره حقيقه ذلك انه رغم كل
القصف المدفعي الشديد الذي كنا نتحدث عنه
في الساعات الاخيره ومنذ ساعات الصباح
والقصف الجوي ايضا كانت هنالك قبل قليل
دفعه من الصواريخ التي انطلقت من احدى
المناطق في شمال قطاع غزه قريبا مننا جدا
اي هنالك اربع قذائف صاروخيه تم اعتراضها
بالقبه الحديديه فيما سقط صاروخان اخران
على مخروبه منا في منطقه مفتوحه وهذا يعني
بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت قادره
على اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه منطقه غلاف غزه
وتوجيه هذه الصواريخ ايضا باتجاه المدن
الاسرائيليه الكبرى كما راينا في الايام
الماضيه عندما كانت هنالك دفعه صاروخيه
كبيره جدا وتكاد تكون غير مسبوقه باتجاه
مدينه تلي ابيب وهذا القصف الصاروخي الذي
طال غلاف غزه قبل دقائق معدوده واشرت انه
جاء من المنطقه الشماليه لقطاع غزه وهذه
نقطه مهمه الان تاتي في وقت كان قائد
الجبهه ال الداخليه التابعه للجيش
الاسرائيلي يتحدث بالامس امام سكان غلاف
غزه في اجتماع معهم ويقول لهم بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي تمكن من القضاء تقريبا بشكل
شبه كامل على القدره الصاروخيه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه من شمال قطاع غزه وهو كان
يحاول ان يقنع هؤلاء الاسرائيليين بالعوده
الى بلداتهم بالعوده الى البلدات
الاسرائيليه في غلاف غزه وهذا ما حاول
ايضا ال اي ناطق العسكري او المتحدثين
العسكريين اقناع الاسرائيليين سكان هذه
المناطق بالعوده الى بلداتهم لكن سلمى الى
اين يعودون وتل ابيب تقصف في الايام
الماضيه اذا نحن امام تطورا حقيقه لافت
جدا ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت قادره
على توجيه هذه الصواريخ باتجاه بلدات غلاف
غزه وفي العمق الاسرائيلي كما شاهدنا في
الايام الماضيه ونحن نرى ان المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه ايه اشتد قصفها في الدقائق
الاخيره وفي منذ ساعات الصباح على المناطق
الشرقيه لجبال وكذلك على المناطق
الشماليه هذا قصف جديد اذا سلمى الان قصف
مدفعي جديد باتجاه جباليا نسمعه بشكل
متكرر وبشكل متواصل في منطقه الغلاف ونسمع
حتى اشتباكات بالرشاشات الثقيله والخفيفه
هذا يعطينا اشاره على ان القوات
الاسرائيليه على الارض ماز زالت تقود
اشتباكات ضاريه واشتباكات وجها لوجه مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ليس فقط في جبال لان
في مناطق اخرى ايضا اي كنا نقف عندها في
بيت حنون وفي بيت لهيه نفس الاشتباكات
نسمعها والجيش الاسرائيلي يستخدم حتى
القنابل الدخانيه في اقامه ستائر دخانيه
في اكثر من موقع في منطقه جباليه وفي
المناطق الشماليه لمدينه غزه وهذا يعني
بان الاشتباكات على اشدها في تك المناطق
حقيقه رغم ان الجيش الاسرائيلي كان يتحدث
في الساعات ال4 الماضيه عن سيطره ناريه
وعن سيطره عمتيه على جباليا وعلى حي
الشجاعيه وعلى غيرها من المناطق في شمال
قطاع غزه لكن من الواضح بان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ما زالت تبدي باسا قويا وباسا
شديدا ومقاومه شرسه ليس فقط على الارض في
مواجهه القوات الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
على اطلاق هذه الصواريخ باتجاه منطقه غلاف
غزه كما شاهدنا قبل دقائق وكانت الصواريخ
حقيقه قريبه منا جدا عندما سقطت وجرى
اعتراض بعضها في السماء اذا هذا هو الموقف
عندنا هنا في المنطقه الشماليه فيما ان
الهجوم العسكري الكبير على الارض يتواصل
ايضا في المنطقه الجنوبيه ص